[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno buenas tardes a todos ya todas hoy
quería hablaros de cuatro cosas quiero
hablaros un poco de plantas de bebidas
de zapatos y de los viajes que tanto nos
gustan no sé si me va a dar tiempo en
estos minutos que nos ha dejado a la
organización lo que sí sé es que a
principios del siglo pasado una empresa
de zapatos mandó a dos de sus
trabajadores a áfrica con objeto puede
empezar a comercializar y vender allí
sus productos a la semana de llegar el
primero de los trabajadores mandó de
vuelta un telegrama a londres diciendo
la situación es inesperada
nadie usa zapatos aquí me vuelvo mañana
a la par el segundo de los trabajadores
mandó el mismo telegrama de reporte y él
decía situación inesperada nadie usa
zapatos aquí todavía la oportunidad es
magnífica esto que ocurre en esta
historia ocurre también en nuestro día a
día hay días que tenemos ganas de hacer
muchas cosas y hay días que no tenemos
ganas de hacer prácticamente ninguna y
lo que diferencia un día de otro en
nuestra vida y lo que diferenció hasta
dos personas es la actitud
la actitud no es solo cómo hacemos las
cosas y de buena o mala gana es también
lo que proyectamos a los demás es como
nos mostramos a los que nos rodean y el
ejemplo más claro de esto más patente
pero tenéis en los niños
mis hijos cuando ya hablo con ellos y le
digo oye íñigo covadonga porque pedrito
es tu amigo
ellos no me dicen no bueno es que
pedrito a pedrito colorea sin salirse
pedido se hace ahora salta a los zapatos
sólo pedrito ya sabe restar no
ellos me dicen por que pedrito es buena
onda porque me gusta estar con él porque
es divertido porque me hace sentir feliz
y eso al final del día es lo que también
buscamos todos y es como nosotros vamos
seleccionando a nuestros amigos por
afinidades por lo que nos proyectan por
lo que nos hacen sentir y esas son las
personas que de verdad perduran cuando
tú entras a una sala y ves a alguien que
me parece de primera es maravillosa pues
esa impresión es difícil de quitar y del
otro lado igual si ves a una persona que
nada más no te cae va a ser muy difícil
que acabe siendo un íntimo amigo tuyo y
alguien relevante en tu vida y eso como
digo es algo que nosotros elegimos
nosotros tenemos la capacidad en nuestro
ser más íntimo de mostrarnos cómo
queremos que nos vean los demás
nos podemos mostrar como una hamburguesa
fantástica maravillosa con carne de kobe
con el mejor queso español el pan
francés más maravilloso o como una de
esas congeladas que se calienta rápido
en el microondas con el pan chicloso o
la carne de vete tú a saber qué y dos
lonchas de queso amarillas bastante
chafas feas eh incomibles
y de igual forma volviendo y reiterando
en esto nos podemos presentar como
queramos nos podemos presentar como un
jardín verde lleno de flores de árboles
maravillosos exóticos o como un jardín
perfectamente marchito y mustio
y hablando de plantas hay una planta que
me gusta especialmente que es el bambú
imagino todos conocéis y el bambú tiene
atrás una historia maravillosa una
historia fascinante el bambú japonés
tarda desde que se planta hasta que
florece aproximadamente 6 años
pero una vez que florecen crece unos 30
centímetros cada 15 días
el mérito creo que no está en esos 15
centímetros no en 30 centímetros cada 15
días está en los seis años anteriores
que el jardinero estuvo regando día con
día esa planta y la estuvo cuidando y la
estuvo protegiendo el jardinero fue
perseverante
qué es la perseverancia la perseverancia
es la capacidad de mantenerse constante
en lo comenzado y se dice mucho más
fácil de lo que se hace a todos nos ha
pasado
empiezas a tocar un instrumento
a las dos semanas no te salen ninguna
canción lo quitas
empiezas a hacer una actividad a
practicar un deporte a jugar tenis no le
pegas ni a la pelota a los 15 días te
quitas
y así con todo
pero el problema es que ese no es el
camino
cuando perseveras
cuando de verdad eres constante es
cuando vienen los éxitos y si no pensase
en vuestros ídolos por ejemplo los
futbolistas los tenistas tienen talento
por supuesto que sí lo tienen
han trabajado han sido perseverantes en
conseguir su objetivo por supuesto que
por supuesto que por supuesto que por
supuesto que sí
igual los actores tienen talento para
interpretar lo tienen seguro pero os
habéis parado a pensar cuántas veces les
han dicho que no en un casting
cuántas veces les han rechazado en una
audición
cuántos papeles secundarios han tenido
que hacer para ser una gran estrella
han perseverado y lo han logrado
y bueno habiendo ya ha pasado por áfrica
por japón habiendo plantado pues otro de
los temas que os quería comentar el tema
de las bebidas no nos merecemos un
refresco después de tanto viaje y más
aún creo que nos merecemos pararnos a
pensar lo que donald kendall que fue un
director de una de las compañías más
importantes de refrescos del mundo dijo
alguna vez y que para mí es una de las
frases que más me ha impactado en mi
vida y que intentó seguir es
prácticamente diaria que es esta éxito
sólo está delante de trabajo en el
diccionario y efectivamente lo está si
te vas al diccionario vas a la página a
250 está éxito y hasta late al final
890 viene trabajo
pero sorpresa solamente viene ahí
no hay nadie nadie nadie que tenga éxito
en ningún plano de la vida personal
profesional
si una cuota de trabajo importante lo
siento pero es así y si no ponemos a
reflexionar
cuando alguna vez habéis tenido un
obstáculo en la vida una piedrita de
estas que pasan en nuestro camino lo
fácil es pues sentarse en la piedrita y
esperar es que algo bueno suceda y nos
solvente el problema
rodearla saltar la es difícil y requiere
la actitud de perseverancia de trabajo y
cuando luego miras atrás y la pasas pues
es bastante más gratificante ver que tú
hiciste ese camino de piedritas y que no
estás sentado cada vez en más piedritas
y un poco en ese viaje os quiero contar
una historia personal como todos podéis
escuchar pues yo soy español llevo ya
varios años viviendo en méxico y la
bueno pues la decisión de venirme no fue
fácil
no fue fácil mucha gente de mi entorno
no le entendía que yo cambiara españa
europa por un país como méxico algunos
incluso me criticaron pero bueno yo
entendí que era el momento de hacerlo
que era pues el paso que continuaba en
mi vida hice de eso me motivó y estoy
convencido además que nadie nunca se
arrepiente de ser valiente
entonces como os digo yo comencé esta
aventura de vivir aquí en méxico hace ya
varios años y recuerdo muy bien que vine
un jueves aquí al df y el lunes empezaba
una capacitación con la empresa que me
trajo en monterrey entonces estaba yo el
domingo ya en el hotel de monterrey
cenando tempranito para estar descansado
y bien el lunes no y me dio un ataque de
lo que los antiguos griegos llamaban
bilis negra
qué es la melancolía me los es negro y
ulises bilis y os puedo asegurar que
duele
y duele mucho sentir el desarraigo
sentir la soledad verte ese joven pero a
la vez muy solo en una habitación de
hotel es complicado y es difícil
yo tuve en ese momento pues quizá la
madurez o la distancia suficiente para
pues para conversar conmigo mismo para
volver a retomar esos motivos y para
fijar la actitud y la perseverancia en
la consecución de esa meta que me había
propuesto pues como como el camino para
lograrlo y bueno lo logré lo logré esa
noche
pero por el camino es difícil muchos
días pues te sientes solo no es fácil
vives lejos a muchas horas de distancia
de tu país natal de tus costumbres y
luego además por el camino pues surgen
dificultades que como digo si una buena
actitud y sin ser perseverante es muy
difícil sobrellevar las y para concluir
únicamente querría decir os quería
recordar varias frases que seguro habéis
escuchado que son que el que quiere
puede
el que busca encuentra
el que siempre recoge y yo de mi lado
también os quiero decir que el que
resiste gana muchas gracias
[Aplausos]